[موسيقى]
تنقسم السحب الى قسمين سحب صيفيه وسحب
شتويه الشتويه امطاروها هتانه اي خفيفه
فحبه المطر صغيره وسحبها منفرشه ومستورده
ولا تعترف بعامل الوقت اي انها تمطر يا
صباح او مساء كل واحد والسحب الصيفيه تسبق
بعصفه ريح وامطارها تكون في بقعه دون
ثانيه وحبه المطر كبيره لها صوت دبدبه ولا
تمطر الا مساءا اي من الظهر وطالع وعاده
ما تكون غزيره وتنتهي بسرعه وفي احايل
تكون مصحوبه بحبات برد الود بين الناس ما
هو مطر صيف تضحك سماء وتختفي في ثواني
الود له قيمه ومعنا وتشريف فيه احترام
طيبه
ومعاني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تم الامطار الشتويه الوسميه والصيفيه
الهريسيه وهي التي تاتي في اخر موسم الصيف
فهي تشبع الاجواء بالرطوبه وتهيا السحب
الوسميه للانطار والعامه يسمون السحاب
الشتوي الماطر بس سحاب المنحدر ليش لانه
ينحدر من طبقات الجو العليا الغير ماطره
الى طبقات الجو السفلى الماطره جيت مثل
السحاب ورحت مثل السراب لاني اول خطاه ولا
انت اخر همومي بيض الله وجه صبر كم هجباب
لين خلي الظنون تنومه والشك
يومي
[موسيقى]